yes I have ascended on this earth to
answer one and one simple question over
will you press the button my superior
motives my highly evolved morals will
guide you through life through this game
you doubt me ha how can you doubt
someone who has not one but two but
three sunglasses let's get into this you
can put anything in any video game ever
including enemies and the blocks
instantly what the [ __ ] does that mean
but you can only play video games for
half your average time so you mean I can
mod oh this must be from a console
peasant who doesn't know about mati
that's cute I will not press the button
adorable this is known as a mod so just
mod it instead yeah yeah that's it
half of ten hours a day is acceptable to
make games infinitely more enjoyable
it's the sky [ __ ] George Lucas just
he wants more of everything in the game
here we have the classic Legend of Zelda
inside the deco tree it has amazing
atmosphere tension it's just this
perfect place but wait look at this
shitty gameplay Oh looks disgusting do
you know how much [ __ ] batter it
would be with a bunch of goranson there
but not one Goren two Goren's three
Goren's five Goren's
look at this gameplay look how it
infinitely our improved
George Lucas was right just like Hitler
I mean look at that this gameplay is so
much more interesting now yeah [ __ ]
dumb pieces
[ __ ] 45 and 55 get out of heat sorry I'm
sorry I got a little caught up on the
first question let's move on
you get the lead role in a movie and you
get paid two million dollars for it it
is instantly well known as the worst
movie of all time and you are hated by
everyone a Nicholas Cage get paid way
more than two million dollars and I'm
pretty sure he doesn't give a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] yes
I will press the but everyone hates me
already yeah I can relate to that too so
I think of you huh what what beautify
plays a final meeting what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is your problem
no one hates me right I'm cool anyway
you can fly but you can't what horse up
fly how is walking a good thing walking
is the worst thing that ever happened to
us
there's cavemen use Forks no they don't
your crush will be your true love and
you will be the most perfect woman you
wish what I will be a perfect woman the
[ __ ] does that mean I am always your
crush will be your true love and we'll
be okay they don't know how to make
proper sentences and will be the most
perfect woman you'd wish for women woman
woman you believe it
Yahoo you will be I don't
your crush will be your true love and
will be the most perfect women you
wished for so it clones itself I I don't
understand so I'm not gonna take a
chance and I'm not gonna click it she
becomes multiple women see that's what I
say
this guy doesn't have a crusher and
don't you just hate when you don't have
a crusher I always feel like when I
don't have a crush and I need to comment
about it online please support me thanks
you acquire your dream body I don't
understand but you have to live with
someone you hate for the rest of your
life I rest my case
you can connect to the internet via your
brain for free like I think that are
they that stupid dude is using a phone
that bad like you do you have to have
like a wireless thing in your brain
really get out of here no I will not you
create the best game in the world but
you cannot play it and can only watch
others play yeah why not why not you
can't play it but you can test it you
can have any power you want but water
kills you how will I live how will I how
long will I live you can live three days
without water one of my power be to
drink water my power would be that water
doesn't kill me what happens then
nothing ah why not you have the ability
to listen to any kind of music anytime
you want
oh you mean like like I can you mean
like we're live in 2015 and you can do
that and you've been able to do that for
years but the music will be blasted and
heard by other people
oh you mean playing it through speakers
the [ __ ] who writes these [ __ ]
questions are you that [ __ ] stupid
they're all about superpowers or would
you sucks like can we get some
interesting ones like would you suck
Megan Fox dick how about that one or if
Hitler was a baby would you murder him
with your own hands can we get some
actual [ __ ] questions not written by
eight-year-old sorry sorry let's keep
going
alright you know what oh they're sick I
can make my own oh okay alright
Hitler is never born but you have to
travel back in time and
choke him with your own hands oh wait
sorry he has to be a baby as well okay
let's do another one
okay here we go here we go you are
dating Serena van der Woodsen what a
dumb [ __ ] name but she has a dick I'm
so much bad at this I'm so much better
at this all right let's go with those
two and see what you bros think see
these are real we crashed a [ __ ]
website good job all right
let's see if my videos have helped you
bros and let's see if if it helped you
improve your your decision-making so
Hitler is never born but you have to
travel back in time and choke baby
Hitler to death with your own hands will
you press the button if you don't press
it you're in a yuria you're a horrible
person you're literally a murderer of
millions of people hmm think about that
but at the same time hmm we kind of
learned from Hitler didn't we
we're like oh yeah let's not be racist
[ __ ] again you know we don't really
have that much to reference in the
modern day uh besides that and you know
what I'm not a huge fan of choking
babies to death I'm sorry so I'm gonna
go nut no I'm not not depression that
button Oh
65 percent yeah right yeah right yeah
right like you would choke a baby get
out of here you are dating Serena van
der Woodsen but she has a dick oh I love
this one I will not press survived
that's disgusting hahaha
oh yeah right 334 percent people ah this
is fun this was really fun
all right breast that's it for today's
episode of will you press a button did
you learn did my infinite wisdom help
you improve yourself that was it for
them please leave a like if you enjoyed
and it's always stay awesome brush I
like nipple black I still fail to see
what everyone hate you I don't like
superheroes
super arrows you will be able to turn
into a person that is 50 meter soul
since when is that a good thing well
lift the proportions